welcome everyone those of you filtering
in please are a couple of seats up front
still and everyone else we got a packed
house today so there's a few seats left
but everyone make a room my name is
Stewart dequeue I'm the program director
at the Yale Center for business and the
environment and we're thrilled today to
have the second talk in our colloquium
on sustainability marketing series this
is sponsored by decra and coordinated by
the Yale Center for business and the
environment and the Yale Center for
customer insights in partnership with a
media partner sustainable brands the
colloquium on sustainability marketing
at Yale sponsored by decra aims to
unravel and address the challenges of
creating environmentally sustainable
products services and brands that
customers love this is the second talk
in a six-part series that will run
throughout the year exploring multiple
perspectives from leading brands who are
pushing conversation thought and action
in this area there's a number of people
we want to thank for this series coming
together it's really been something that
a lot of us have put a lot of time
effort and energy into you know I'll get
this thanking our sponsor Anastasia
Roark from Decorah who if anybody's
interested in sustainability consulting
and work in this area is the best
combination she is a local presence with
a global company so for any student
that's interested in this a great person
to talk to and chat with Marissa Galicia
and Laura Frances Cheney are two of the
students that have been instrumental in
making sure that this all comes together
and happens in the correct way and
finally we really want to thank in
particular we're get two introductions
in a bit but we want to thank Vincent
Stanley from Patagonia for those of you
who are here last year
Vincent spent two days on campus meeting
with folks talking with people really
getting a whole group of students in the
community around here engaged on this
topic and you know from that we had a
series of subsequent meetings and
conversations and you know at a very
early stage he helped us think through
how we wanted to present this series the
kind of topics that we wanted to address
the things that were really
for us and was just extremely generous
with his time and energy and insight and
so before we get started I just wanted
to thank Vinson because he really played
a huge role in getting this all together
and without further ado I'll introduce
our sponsor Anastasia O'Rourke who's a
principal at Dec Rock consulting
sustainability and performance
excellence
she's also the co-chair of the
sustainability sustainable purchasing
Council and a member of the Advisory
Board of the new net sustainable public
purchasing initiative
Anastasia please come on up Thanks hi
everyone welcome just to two seconds of
welcome really what a thrill it is to
have you hear such a leading company
leading brand and we're really excited
to hear everything that you are able to
share with us today and welcome also to
those participating in the webcast if
you have questions when we get to a
question and answers please type them in
the chat and we have students here who
are moderating that and we'll transmit
those up to our speakers and it's my
pleasure to introduce Mary Ann Scherr
tell who is moderator for the session
today she is the professor of industrial
environmental management here at Yale
and she's also the president of the
International Society for industrial
ecology expert in this topic expert in
supply chains is a fun great moderator
and I'm honored also because she was
voted by PhD advisors here so it's
always lovely to be on the podium so
welcome and over to you Mary Ann thank
you
thank you it's great when one of your
former PhD students is now sponsoring of
a wonderful lecture series with great
aplomb so thank you Anastasia thanks to
stew and to the Center for what do you
call those business in the environment
yeah is it it's still it yeah well at
the world Stu's been doing in a fabulous
job and I also want to thank Maria and
Laura who prepped me so that I would
pronounce a few things right I guess and
by way of introduction I would just like
to tell you my first two very memorable
experiences about Patagonia back in the
90s we had a Dean named Jerry Cohen he's
the only Dean we've ever had who was an
engineer and he's just retired he left
he went directly from here to Carnegie
Mellon University where he was president
for the last 15 years and he has done a
wonderful job there so he's a great guy
and he wasn't quite as familiar with
fundraising and environmental companies
so somebody in our development staff
sends him out to visit Patagonia and
he's trying his best to understand
what's going on in the culture and he's
got some meetings set up and all of a
sudden he hears Surf's Up
and of course everyone leaves their desk
and well you can guess what they do next
they go surfing so that's one of the
advantages of location and that was a
great way for Jerry to really understand
the culture in fact the founder of
Patagonia Yvan Chen yard has been our
guest here at the school several times
and his first book was called let my
people go surfing so you can see that
culture is strong at Patagonia as these
little stories tell you the other thing
I must acknowledge as my colleague Reliv
said is here in the editor of the
Journal of industrial ecology and we're
now on what what volume 18 years of
publishing the journal and in the very
first issue we had a story a great story
about Patagonia one of the authors was
Mike Brown who was our still our very
good friend was at Patagonia for many
years and is now one of the great
environmental consultants in the field
so we have a little bit of the coal
we don't shout Surf's Up much around
here but you know with climate change
and everything so there there are at
least three stories here everyone from
Patagonia talks about stories and two of
the stories are Vincent and Jill and the
other is the story of Patagonia so I'm
just gonna briefly introduce Vincent and
gel so you officially know who they are
in case you missed it but I'm gonna ask
you both to say a little bit more about
who you really are and how you might
describe yourself as you share with us
the context and and the story of
Patagonia many of us think we know but
there are a lot of a never I talk with
anyone from Patagonia there's always
some subtleties and new ways of
understanding how you became such a
unique and important brand in proving
out so much of what we today call
sustainability so Vincent Stanley is
officially acting vice president of
marketing but as I learned last year
he's really one of the kind of one of
the founders with the invention yard and
certainly aide-de-camp and trusted
Vizier Patagonia was founded in 1973 and
Vincent you've been there since the
beginning so you have you know lots of
tails let me just say a couple of other
things about Jill as you as you wouldn't
be too surprised Jill's titled as
director of environmental strategy but
the truth is she's been at Patagonia
since 1989 so she's been everywhere you
know from the fabric laboratory to the
footprint chronicles many of us recall
both of you have been heavily involved
with the common threads partnership and
that's the one where every Patagonia
product can be returned for recycling
and so you've really been key not only
to the to the business but also to
promoting and expanding the culture that
you've that's so special at Patagonia so
um I guess for Founders tales we should
turn to you Vincent and then to Jill
it's it's interesting that you mentioned
Surf's Up because I actually it was a
great career move for me in Patagonia
not to surf I came to work at the
company for intending to work for about
six months
my uncle's emulsion arms so the the shop
as we called it ssin art equipment was
about half an hour away and I started
off as a as a packer but pretty soon it
became apparent that when the surf was
up I was the only one who answered the
phones so I I was made sales manager at
the age of 21 and and did that for about
20 years and then I wanted to it had I
realized that 3 to 6 months that gone on
for 20 years so I left the company to
teach myself how to write and continue
to write also for the company and to be
involved in some of its major programs
and then came back about 10 years ago as
the head of the editorial department and
got engaged with Jill and creating the
footprint chronicles and some of the
common threads programs and then got
snookered into taking the role of vp of
marketing for the last year and a half
which is now coming to an end today so
we have the permanent replacement is
starting in Ventura in about 30 minutes
unless the surfs up know she's from
Boston so she may not know
and in just a couple of words of context
I think it's interesting to have if the
title of this talk is don't buy this and
Patagonia is an aspirational company you
might wonder what are we are aspiring to
particularly if we're a consumer
products company that talks about don't
buy this and I think that ultimately
what we're aspiring to is to be a
company 10 15 or 20 or 50 years down the
line that actually justifies its
existence that is worthy of being a
company and business and I think that
this has this aspiration has come to us
very much over time over the course of
the 40 years we did not start out
wanting to be anything but the company
that made the best mountain climbing
equipment and then the company that made
the best clothing for layering for the
mountains but because we had come out of
the surfing in the mountaineering worlds
I think we had this strong sense of
attachment to the wilderness I think
we've talked about this before that it's
it's something that's very hard to
explain to anybody who doesn't share it
but for anybody who's you know been more
than a mile from the road head and
experienced the kind of the AAB that you
feel when you're no longer certainly at
the top of the food chain when you're
sensitive to that the natural world is
much more beautiful than anything we can
create ourselves and you get this not
only in the mountains but you get this
in the surf like ten feet from the sand
when you're out there in the waves
playing with natural forces so this led
us our aspiration that became very early
on was to help protect natural places
and this we started doing in the 80s by
giving 1% of sales to the environment
but it took us much much longer to
view ourselves to look at ourselves as
environmental culprits or villains to
look at what was done in our name and
the supply chain what we had done in our
name in the supply chain and to really
examine our own practices and then
gradually improve them so the aspiration
has grown rather than diminished
particularly over the past 20 years and
I think that's what we want to touch on
today as well how does how does that
work what happens when you do one thing
and it teaches you that oh it's possible
we can do something else so just like
that's my sort of setting for the
conversation good afternoon thanks for
having us um so I've been with the
company since 1989 as Maryann said and
I've had the fortunate position of being
very involved in our supply chain and
Ren worked in the fabric department and
ran the fabric department for many years
and after 14 years of that moved into
the environmental Department which
sustainability work became a much more
corporate wide role for me where I was
very focused on product I didn't really
pay attention to our buildings and all
that stuff before moving into the
environmental department so I've had the
advantage of taking very deep product
knowledge marrying it with the
environmental knowledge that I really
learned on the job I was a textile major
so I didn't have the benefit of
Education many of you have now and and
have applied that to how we can be very
practical in that in that information
understanding how a supply chain works
what are the challenges what are the
benefits and and how do we instill our
message to our suppliers and get them to
be our partners to do the things that
we're trying to do and aspire to so
Vincent and I have worked very closely
together especially on the
communications piece of the work that I
do and how do we try to tell that in a
digestible way because um so many of the
things we work on are quite complex and
you lose most customers after about the
first three sentences if you're not
careful so we've tried to figure out
ways to be engaging
some of this information across can you
see a little bit more about that yeah
absolutely so you know I think early on
we learned that the points that
motivated us as a company to make change
aren't always the things that motivate
consumers to support our choices and one
example comes from way back in the 90s
with organic cotton and as we learn more
about how conventional grown cotton was
done at the time it was really
disconcerting to see all the chemicals
in the cotton fields and we spent a lot
of time driving around cotton fields to
learn this and as we learned some of
that information that was really the
compelling reason why we switched and we
wanted to tell our consumers that look
at all this stuff that's happening we're
really concerned we want you to be
concerned and our so we made posters
with crop dusters and all these things
and our retail employees came back said
you know you're really kind of bumming
everybody out and the focus groups are
like you know we happy when we're
shopping you got your dog and a latte
and now we're looking at crop dusters
and and so we we learned that we had to
meet them where they were ready to be
met in the environment they were and
that at the time was our retail stores
in our catalog this was pre-internet
which definitely dates me but we had to
figure out how to engage them in the
conversation and not turn them off with
the very first point of communication so
we had to match and sort of balance the
crop duster in photos with a farmer that
was growing organic cotton and tell his
positive stories and what why he made
the switch his personal reasons for
getting the chemicals off of his land
and so it was really a lesson in
balancing that information that it's not
always the motivating factor that
resonates so we've introduced a concept
that's really core to talking about
Patagonia and that is the sort of the
tensions in the relationship between
marketing and being a business and
sustainability and the way that you've
done it in the as you've started to
describe so that the customer can
understand so let me throw
this question has the public's reaction
to Patagonia clearly it's influenced you
you've said that you needed to kind of
meet them halfway but how does the
messaging that you do sort of shaped the
company and what the company does and
how does what the company does shape the
messaging Vincent I think it definitely
works that way
our initial how we speak to our
customers I think was many of you know
this story when we when we were a
climbing equipment company we were
making we were heavily dependent on
making something called Pitons
you'd hammer those into the cracks when
climbing got popular the cracks started
to deform because there was so much
pressure on these roots so we undertook
this process to introduce another kind
of piece of gear it was aluminum chalks
that were not hammered in but torqued in
but to do this we had to persuade
climbers who were really trusting their
lives on this gear to change entirely to
a whole different means of protection
and it took us about six months eight
months to do this the the first thing we
did was start to make these chalks that
had they were the the replacement gear
they had been made in Britain but not
they weren't familiar people in the US
were not familiar with them we put a 13
page essay in our catalog called the
whole natural art of protection and that
was picked up by all of the climbing
magazines and so within about six months
to eight months we saw this radical
shift so this the business had been 70%
reliant on Pitons at the end of one year
was 70% reliant on chalks and we knew
that we could talk to our customers have
we talked to our customers as grown-ups
and we could engage them with an issue
we could bring about a successful change
but in the as Jill pointed out in the
case of organic cotton people were not
as interested in that mess
but it took us it took us longer and it
was changing with Pitons made us
confident that we could actually make
the change and persuade get our
customers to at least to accept organic
cotton one of the things that happens
with messaging is that the message gets
across once you have a success doing
something it actually creates internal
pressure to do something more
so the messaging when we have gotten
something across like organic cotton it
then creates the pressure what's our
next step what are we we've made this
move to reduce the harm we do by
abandoning conventional cotton and using
organic what are other areas of the
company that we can make change in and
how do we communicate it so when a
successful it feeds back to you and you
people start expecting you to become a
leader and you start to feel conscious
of that you want to meet people's
expectations and not and not let them
down and also not let down the the
obligation you feel as a as a business
person to reduce the harm you do do you
want to comment on this circle about the
message shaping what the company does
but also the company having to respond
to the message yeah I think I mean it's
a healthy tension and so it tension
isn't always bad and I think sometimes
we look at it as bad and healthy tension
is really good because it makes both
sides better and in our storytelling we
always want to be able to answer every
question that might come but again we
have to be careful with the the balance
and not have it be this fire hose of
information that you can't swallow it
and allow people to come in at a level
that they can digest it and become
educated and we see ourselves a lot as
educators around environmental issues
whether it's a campaign with an NGO that
we're working on or something about our
own prac
and learning sort of that cadence of
information that people can absorb and
then react to and hopefully spring into
action and that's a lot of the work that
we do is trying to get people into
action whether it be our consumers our
colleagues at work our supply chain
competitors that type of thing so you
know I think over the years like Vincent
said as we had successes you become more
comfortable in that tension and that
discomfort that exists because you see a
problem you don't really know the answer
but you know you have the mechanism to
find it so as you introduce new things
into the supply chain new things into
the business you have the confidence
that if you stick with it and persevere
you're going to figure out how to manage
it and work on it but you don't know
what you certainly don't know the answer
when you're starting and so I think it's
a you know it is a circular tension and
process that we often go through often
without knowing it actually I would say
it's become a little bit subconscious at
this point this is an interesting
I think the footprint chronicles there
with communication and transparency
there are often happy unintended
consequences when we when we put the
footprint chronicles out our goal was
essentially to create a CSR report that
people would read that was literate and
then it was engaging for the customer
and so what we did is we featured I
think of the first season five products
and we talked about the greenhouse gas
emissions generated that the energy used
the waste generated and eventually went
to water but we also we also put in a
narrative about okay this is what we
like about what we do with this product
we use recycled polyester we use organic
cotton this is what we think is still a
problem and this is what we think we'll
do next so the idea was really to talk
to consumers and in a sotto voce way to
NGOs who were asking these questions but
the unintended consequences were there
are a couple of interesting things first
I had been with the company more or less
since the beginning and I noticed after
footprint
calls that we had a great reduction in
the number of hostile water-cooler
conversations that come about when
people talk about what we're trying to
do environmentally and how irrelevant it
is to the business there was still that
kind of much more that kind of tension
in the company before footprint
chronicles when we had actually
explained to our own people a lot of
what we were doing and we actually
elevated the conversation so that you
still have the bickering back and forth
but the bickering is smarter and then
the the second unintended consequence we
noticed that our production people who
had been kind of nervous when we were
you know putting up the factories on the
website and talking about what we liked
and didn't like about what they were
responsible for that they started to
come to us because they found the
footprint chronicles a tool for working
with the suppliers to improve practices
another unintended consequence that we
found out that suppliers wanted to be
mentioned on the footprint chronicles
even if they were mentioned critically
because it gave them some face to the
consumer and faced with other businesses
so what we had started out intended to
do was rather limited and the benefits
were extensive and kind of across from
customer to supplier to employee the
benefits and to the general public
because we got a lot of attention so so
I want to break down the wee a little
bit cuz yeah you know companies speak in
one voice is we've learned that the
watercooler that may be different
opinions when you change the message or
you go with a new message don't buy this
for example how does this get how does
this filter through your organization
and different departments or different
levels and so forth I mean I think when
we're most successful at it is when we
figure out the touch points to a lot of
different employees and it's really easy
I think to think about the
sustainability work internally or the
communications to sit in one
apartment or that is Vincent's job or
that's Jill's job and what I think both
of us have tried really hard to do over
the years is to spread that
responsibility throughout the
organization so for example with the
footprint chronicles team we pulled
together a team of people that knew each
other because our campus is fairly small
but we didn't work together we hadn't
done a project together and and to watch
people shift during that process was one
of my most rewarding experiences at the
company because we watched a team come
together put in place really a directive
of the management to do this project
but this group was made up of all
different people from the video team
that edit team the materials team the
web team and we weren't used to just
making all the decisions and the team
went from asking well who's gonna go
tell the vice presidents this is what we
want to do and I said they don't they
don't or what are they asking them what
to do to telling them what we want to do
and it's a really it was a really
important shift for us because it was
his group that didn't feel empowered
when they came yet they were given that
responsibility and they felt empowered
when they left to take that part of
their work into the other parts of their
job and we really saw that flourish
which was really exciting to watch and
it was a really great reminder how
important it is to spread this
responsibility out into the organization
so you have people on different places
working towards the same goal and
actually moved out it was contagious so
we had the team that was responsible for
creating the footprint chronicles but
then once we started to engage the
production staff more heavily they began
to behave just like the team that was
working on the Chronicles so they were
tremendously self directed and
self-motivated to get things done now
sometimes I am teaching a course this
semester called corporate environmental
management and strategy and sometimes
there are very difficult trade-offs as
as you progress you know there might be
a technical product requirements
and you really need to use something
even if it isn't the most environmental
product can you can you give us an
example of of a challenge like that
where you really had to make some kind
of a difficult choice in that way yeah
there's a current one that we're in the
middle of actually and that's around
performance characteristics in Alpine
and ski gear specifically around
waterproofing and trying to balance what
is the performance requirement of a
product in the scheme of the durability
over a lifetime and the performance and
environmental ramifications of some of
the chemicals that are needed to do that
so in the our case it's around durable
water repellent finishes which is what
you apply to the outside so you stay dry
in a rainstorm and we have reported as
Vincent said on the footprint chronicles
about the use of this chemistry and
trying to figure out how to reduce the
environmental impacts yet maintain a
level of performance that still keeps
the product competitive in the market
and useful that if we were to diminish
some of these performance
characteristics the life of the garment
is going to be much much shorter and
it's going to entice people to buy
something newer sooner and so then you
look at the impacts of everything else
in that jacket from the drilling and
refining of oil all the way up to
consumer care and and that's a really
hard balance do you then reinvest all
these new resources because of this one
chemical or do you put play a process in
place in your supply chain to
responsibly handle that chemical and
look to see where are you where might
you be contributing to the bigger
environmental impact so those are some
of the very real tensions that we deal
with on a daily basis and partly what we
use to determine some of that is our
mission statement which the middle
statement is cause now on
sorry harm and we use that mission
statement actually on a regular basis in
the company and especially when I was in
product I would say to designers that
would come and with some new idea is it
necessary for what we're trying to
achieve and one example where we said no
was at one point somebody came with a
coating that had a metallic component on
the inside and the idea was you flex
your body heat it reflects back to you
and it's warmer than a jacket without it
so okay but how much warmer like are we
really gaining something by that you put
on your insulate of layers before your
jacket how I mean is it a gimmick or is
it real and is it necessary harm for the
increased performance and in that case
we decided it wasn't that the mining of
the metals and the implications that
followed that and the processes it was
it couldn't fulfill our mission
statement and so we did say no so there
are those times as well where we will
look to see is it really necessary no
that can be achieved through another way
nice that's a very interesting example
because you also you want to be the real
you want to do and that's certainly very
important now you're not exactly the
biggest company in the country and yet
you want to influence your suppliers and
it's hard for the little guy to
influence suppliers sometime how can you
influence your sort of tier 1 and tier
two suppliers beyond your own own work
and get the kind of results that you're
looking for maybe talk even more broadly
Vincent about supply chain relationships
at Patagonia
yeah you know we've talked about this
quite a bit I think in the beginning
they were when we wanted to work on a
problem we would often find somebody say
a fabric problem or something or go back
to the case of when we needed to find
paper catalog paper with recycled
content that could be FSC certified that
was capable of reproducing high quality
photograph
in a lot of cases we find partners for
two reasons one we find somebody because
we have a reputation for doing
environmental work and they if they team
up with Patagonia they get a kind of
luster from that association but also in
many cases we work with people who have
an interest who want to do less
environmental harm when we got going in
organic cotton the fellow who agreed to
be our our spinner really did it for
moral reasons and not for business
reasons he he thought it was a great
business challenge in order to meet a
kind of moral or personal objective so
those are those are two ways in which we
work with individual suppliers but the
other the thing that's been a big move
for us over the we've been associated
with a lot of different groups including
the textile exchange including 1% for
the planet but the big initiative for
the last three years has been the
sustainable apparel coalition which we
actually convened with joint Patagonia
Walmart stationary which had it's only
its its one and only use was to invite
the heads of 616 corporation it's been I
want to let Jill talk about that because
she's very intimately involved in it but
that is - actually it kind of goes back
to the creation of what is certified
organic food the actual creation of
certification or the agreement on terms
is really significant to making advances
and that's been the first step of the
sustainable apparel coalition is
actually to agree on on standards to
create baseline memberships and then the
idea then is to make improvements yeah
and I think really a lot of our
experience today is around forming those
relationships in the supply -
and they're critical to getting it done
and I feel like I've told people for 20
years my job is convincing people to do
stuff with was not a small undertaking
at the time and we used to joke it was
the lunch break they would spin our yarn
and but today we have another project
that's along those same lines and it's
this regenerative wool project coming
out of South America and it's one of my
new favorite projects and it's actually
one of my proudest things that we've
done as a company looking back at all
the 20 years because it's actually a
regenerative project and by placing
business in these devastated grasslands
of South America with these new
management and grazing systems the
grasslands are coming back to life and
they're actually being regenerated so
we're we're contributing to making
something really good in our supply
chain instead of just trying to sustain
it and it very much speaks to your
question of the small guys we were
approached by a for press not unlike we
have often reached out into our supply
chain of companies that we either felt
might have some tolerance for this
hopefully interest or ones like
Vincent's example from the spinning mill
somebody that didn't understand it but
really got behind it once they
understood it so it's all about a lot of
education context building for the
larger issue that we just I got an email
the other day from a woman about the
whole project she read about it in the
Nature Conservancy's magazine they're
also a partner in the project there's a
big article right now on their website
around it thanking us because she was a
bird person in Canada that cared about
the migratory path so the birds that
land in South American grasslands on
they're in their annual cycle and it was
such a great reminder of the full
ecosystem that we're working in and I
sent it to our production people I sent
it to the people that get mired in the
orders and trying to fit everything
together so they see the larger context
but then these smaller partners have
access to the market and access to
things and they can see the the more
detailed things so it's you know I think
it's those relationships for me are
super super key that no matter how small
you are as
company I really feel like there's a way
to worm your way in because I've done it
and bliss I will say because he's
knowing now I would be a lot more
bashful I think is another another
interesting component that the the
farmers were working with in South
America are like 5th generation some of
them they came there their ancestors
came over and that survived as farmers
unless the grassland is restored and one
of the shifts in their thinking is they
now think of themselves primarily as
grass farmers that's what they're
producing as grass and and incidentally
how they make their money their business
model is to is to sell the Sheep that
eat the grass but that that that shift
of focus I think is something that well
I've asked many questions I have many
more of my students know that I'm very
interested in corporate culture and
change and types of ownership and
succession and all the things but I
think it's more important to really turn
this over to the audience and start to
generate the some of your questions no
thank you both for being here so much
this is great and Pedigo needs a really
inspiring company but I wanted to ask
you about the decision behind that don't
buy this campaign and the black ball
right Friday ad and one of you tell us
if there about whether there was any
internal discussion or what the internal
discussion was about about whether to
put out that ad and specifically how
consumer products come doing so many
things to make sure those products are
sustainably sourced yeah we the reason
for the ad came about as an extension of
the common threads program and the
common threads program the idea started
in 2005 we were influenced by the work
of William McDonough we wanted to do
cradle to cradle manufacturing and we
want to take back every product we'd
ever made so we started on this
ambitious recycling program within about
two years we realized you know this is
this is not recycling is only one
component
of reducing material consumption and
increasing resource efficiency the whole
classic argument of the four R's would
reduce repair reuse those were important
elements and there was a reason for the
particular order they came in so we
started to expand the common threads
program to include reduce how does the
companies say we want you to buy less
but where the important statement is not
that we want customers to buy less but
the important statement is that we want
customers to buy what they need and to
reduce unnecessary consumption I don't
think I think basically this is an
extension of the position we take in
making a high quality product if you
make a product that a akut that lasts
three times longer than your competitors
or let's say twenty percent longer than
your competitors theoretically you're
losing out on repeat sales and this is
harmful to your to your business on the
other hand if your jacket lasts longer
and your happy customer tells somebody
else you draw more customers to you you
increase the loyalty of customers who
are going to come back to you to buy
another product you improve your
reputation so we saw this as an
extension of offering high quality
products reducing perhaps the number of
sales we might get but improving the
loyalty of the customers we have and
gaining new customers who hadn't bought
from us before yes
my name is Clara I'm a first year
masters of Environmental Management
student here at FES my question is about
how you've seen product prices and
potentially consumer demographics change
with your changing aspiration and
whether or not you think that
potentially reinforces ideas that
sustainability and responsibility are
sort of luxury ideas well I think with
more companies engaging in it it's
easier because there's an economy of
scale that develops and that is a huge
part of our business is economy of scale
and part of our sharing of our
information with our competitors
sometimes is a business actually have
set up a little booth at a trade show
ourselves saying please come use some of
this wool because we know we can't
sustain the goals that are there so
economies of scale help a lot I think
also in the years we've been doing this
now we've seen kind of in the early
years all the green consumers yes we'll
pay more and then you put it to the
general public and that doesn't really
happen but I think now we're seeing a
shift that people care more about the
origin of their products they care more
about where things are coming from I've
said to a few people here it's always a
great reminder to be on universities and
seeing the different generations where
the upcoming ones are used to this
transparent lifestyle and it's not only
comfortable but it's expected where is
even in where I said it's still a little
like really you want to know what that
was on Facebook I mean and so it you
know it's I think there's this shift and
and with that shift people understand
more of what's happening which hopefully
allows them to understand the value of
the pricing that exists on it and the
footprint chronicles was a big big help
in that because you know I think when
marketing is really good recycled
polyester you throw your bottled in the
recycling you get a jacket it seems
really simple like you turn the light
switch on and everything's recycled in
your line but the footprint chronicles
started to get to what were the real
issues that happen in a supply chain to
make these shifts and then people could
kind of
stand it a little bit so I still don't
think we're at the point that we can put
anything out there and put an
environmental benefit on it and charge
whatever it is we want they're still
very real tensions around cost of doing
some of this stuff and what's
competitive in the market but I feel
like we're we're getting a deeper
understanding which I think will help in
the long run there's something else just
like to to mention cuz you're always
kind of starting out in your in your
work lives and the conditions on the
planet are gonna be very different and
if we start to actually you mean what we
have right now in business is private
profits and socialized costs in terms of
the costs of the environment or some
cost to communities when when people are
paid fairly and if we start to assign
those costs the way they should be the
cost of products might go up and we
might have a very different kind of
economy in 2050 too than we have now
which is based on very very cheap
historically very very cheap products
and the ability of people to buy them
very frequently so you know I'm just
kind of giving you the kind of the
long-range answer to that I'm not so I'm
not so sure that things aren't going to
get more expensive if life gets fairer
and I wanted to hear more about your
conversations that you have with your
customers and you know difference in
segments and how you approach them and
how you get feedback on all these
different initiatives that you've talked
about you know it's not the most of it
is anecdotal
you know we rely on the emails we get we
we don't do a lot of customer analysis I
think one thing that's interesting for
our company is because we have a lot of
pretty devoted employees and almost that
kind of represent our customer base so
they become the guinea pigs so for
instance there was a question I didn't
answer on dunk by this jacket is how did
you sell that internal
well one thing is we circus cussin on
that and then by the time we ran that ad
about the only one who really didn't
like it was my wife but we did get a lot
of support and we kind of gauge it's
it's it's informal but so far it's been
effective as we grow we're going to have
to start to do more in more formal
market research and one of the things
with the web that's now about twenty
percent of our business is that you can
do rather extraordinary algorithms and
segmentation in terms of how you send
messages to customers so that you don't
piss them off there's a just read a very
interesting book on the 2012 campaign
I'm talking about for uncertain voters
in Ohio right before the election the
the Democrats had it down so that they
would they knew which so that those
those people were not contacted but they
were almost driven to the polls whereas
the Romney supporters were sent 60
pieces of mail in the week before and so
that kind of sophistication to reach
customers I feel like our customers
questions are getting better we have an
excellent customer service team so we
don't see the vast majority of questions
that come in because they're able to
answer them but then we get the ones
they can't answer and they asked us to
help and contribute to the answers and
they're getting deeper and more educated
questions and that's a let's go to the
side make you run a little bit Marissa
don't worry about people leaving with
Achmed but there's still there's still
some people that are real tears no sorry
so my name is Laura I'm at the Law
School and just to build on the question
about consumers willingness to pay from
the supply chain side in the business
consideration point Patagonia has built
a reputation and a brand on the
sustainability but for this to really
have an impact what you're going to need
is to extend the sort of supply chain
practices that you engage in to I mean I
saw H&M was on the sustainability in the
coalition or j.crew sort of more
mainstream companies at this point or in
the future do ending and end a choice
that you make on a moral grounds I think
there will always be environmental
initiatives that will cost more but I
also think the business imperative is
there when you look at the resources in
our world and we're living in a
resource-constrained world that start to
have business impacts and the example
i've used this morning a couple
discussions is the drought in Texas a
couple years ago was very very severe
and cotton crops couldn't be grown so
big cotton grow businesses that rely
almost exclusively on cotton for their
sales had to shift and they lost sales
because the raw material wasn't there so
when you look at resources that are
shifting diminishing that are
constrained if you're working with mills
and supply chains that are very
efficient and this might be more the
case of water in a dye house type of
thing in 10 to 15 years they're probably
the ones that are going to be here so I
think we're starting to see examples
it's not overall every year but we're
starting to see incidents that are
really real from a business imperative
that if you are working with efficient
amount of resources you probably are
going to survive longer so right now it
might be a little bit more expensive
right now it might take a little bit
more work but really when I look at how
we evaluate our supply chain that's part
of it and we want to be working with
vendors that can
be in business in ten to fifteen years
that can operate in a
resource-constrained environment because
I really think that's where we're
heading I don't think it's it just do it
yeah that's right um I think I'm gonna
reserve the last question for myself
because it's a little sensitive and I
want to be the one who asks it but we
talk about the values of the founder we
talk about internal pressures and
external pressures and there's a
different mix of all of those in every
company and in every organization and
you know Yvonne Chen yard is such a
well-known I kind of clastic figure
iconic an iconoclastic I think and we've
seen it interface and we've seen we've
seen some changes Apple you know what
something's going to happen and that's
just happens to all of us I think and
you know what happens when the founder
or the visionary or the the values of
the founder permeate and if the founders
no longer there what happens and where
do you go I think it will be very
difficult for you've almost already kind
of starting to withdraw from I mean he
was never an active manager he always
spent six months away from the company
but he intervened wherever he felt
necessary and he was instrumental in
product for a long time he's starting to
back off now he's almost 75 but I think
there are a couple of things that are
that are in our favor or three things
one is that the family will continue to
only own the company and the kids have
grown up with the same values as their
parents the second is we were able to
become a B Corp B corpse became legal in
California last year and we were among
the first companies so we can actually
write our values into our Charter and
our Articles of Incorporation and in our
case we we wrote it in that it requires
- any change in those values requires a
unanimous
of the board you don't have to do that
if you want to be a B Corp but we did so
that's those are two advantages the
family being a B Corp but the third is
also the this the strength of the
passion of the of the workforce at the
middle management level that I think as
time and again actually kept us on
course because the knowledge of
processes runs very deep within the
company and people are people care so
you know ten years from now take a look
and see what you see but I use the the
natural shifts that come and the jockey
that come whenever you have a big change
in the company fortunately for us we've
been in a constant state of change for
forty years it won't be anything greatly
new to be there well that's something to
be applauded and I we want to thank you
very much for joining us and sharing